[Music]
andré street journal steam december will
welcome the voice of the financial steel
tanks of x minus 5 and x lvb youths call
stan what the button aniele get started my
patrick sponge and grains over sixty
seven years old market with close to the
financial  industry give you just your
credit card priors
two news about charging anniversary
motion cell
these cleveland experts of having image
all the companies in brazil and 20h
some
in 2012 the opportunity of starting
something with my call product
developed from the scratch so when the
to sleep  jumping together that would be
ten times bad and the name containers sbo
wc
who has be much much better and
thames of product and in great great
customer service at anger and most
customer switching the financial
industry is something that people were
not used to think about  in the queen of
distribution channel that cost leave the road
so martians cross with you in a
small series on the country and rode also
directly left dam and you the voice there
nothing and yoke the explosive disorder he
would i think the business within leica
d-  lux 5 de 10 years for my girl and
other areas
okay folks so de gary sauvegarde de
premiums because it was de my ping pong
ball by morning in the beginning
my files in 2012 by the style en
polio ladder produce and presenting
produce little animal in  mosul dam bi
lesbian have die succesful en and
adopted by er klein pso het we tried to
provide what they want again beer in
the company van de kleins profile 2
stan span fell zo wie try de winter
vote what they want and in many things
30  because have to push the financial
industry won't those and accounts d
johnny the bank within you an account to
make white trash ocb the bios if you have the
credits run their businesses to help
them grow are ex vs oil provider what
i all that edition so ceiling  dat is
acquiring banking credit and i also
provided and credit and were provided
and software
ze rather direct two widgets giving them
such as to help them become more
productive and grow their businesses
why not change anything coming fitness
over aperture rather stone the step into
a soldier  get yes saving your head to
head internal
and and technology background to think
like that and having the huddle angelus
zoey could be chip there much more
efficient
we for the technology cries from
scratch we could provide and many other
features that for them would be very
difficult to to to create and we think
about
software or details wifi buy new
features and the sutter
nothing for the optimal to to bring
new and more functional is the customer's
and minutes then had the mindset of
pudding small first wimps and coach
typical for this income  and banks to
think like that but now that other
person in september again
countryfield again positive earn a furry
in a jeweler's baby
what's it like rate namibie business one
person more plugins up work so
visit to easy peasy cottage business
environment which is not  easy to
in australia business to easy to be
manager by letter i something becoming bad
something the king
much better because no single digit
interest rates is thumping there
structurally the economy on the country and that
that by itself or adha help salah
but the finds so  a netherfield and
longbourne that the intro level spirit is
coming to give you some how
will you see stores university tax
assurance and see many other like it's a
young people you know that must be calm
and entrepreneur with then star that's why
business which is great something like that and
coaching generational move that might
incorrect people to start their own
business and win in life and read more
p more texas en in play more people and
great progress and you remain i am a
girl i started the force company georg
listing en je d'éducation  so efficient
in winter imperial walden and amber
educational activities 12 telephone at
the doorbell watch you and education space and
why you we also wel wel driver show vol is
rené sierkip dat lily was so dat is in
possible to help the symposium not to
help with see  that e-mail or salon that
is in a public school or public school
in which you can not i don't give
to this kit de in a great interest in
the great to study
bodykit ones to do something you really
great kids de your  problem to this cool
in people cannot find them and their an
assistant at someone that is a special
the latest beat second 3 family and
they by him but tuckers something cools
discourse in bless you are terrible the
public schools and the weather guide to help
is to  identify these people so young ones
the week i want to win a live once a
great progress donor i shackly how what
they want to study the one more
knowledge
so my day racism hi find someone that
want to share my knowledge and try to
bring them close to  be afraid to provide
them
more resources to stay together school's
and to have access to to to to other
source of knowledge and to go and carry
them to studio
whenever they want in the world they can
come to stanford
so encourage them to say whatever they
want  so am wendy so have input and
early age the fact that they can really
be com
simon reuters van girl multi-country
great to see the younger generation
business winters a person already
finished den education de memorabilia much op op
to those people am not stupid
last tassel for you [ __ ] other tool
clock in the morning and you lie you
just got there the ceiling and you thinking about
the future stone
what will i do my family give you up at
night they were you want a company that
you wanna be spending  time to make sure
the horizon founded
nou on the ten is a cannon the client
fresh and we never an lauwereins crazy to
getting stable in the company and disrupt
the relationship that accompany
restore strip
the comfort and the relationship that
accompanies thomas by the small pace
and  green de customer and lily tryin to
be length from what they heard
nut in vent in function of the maize
angelique chairman of stone thank you so
much trouble in all the way from san
paulo what de star for screening do
you have beak en campus whenever you  go work
come here
alexa rank is its time
[Music]